valley businesses have tough decisions
to make about
mask requirements and proof of
vaccinations thank you for joining us
tonight at 11 i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez now this comes
after the cdc recently announced fully
vaccinated people
don't need to wear a mask in most
settings oracle man joining us now live
from downtown with what some businesses
are doing
well denise and brian following that
guidance from the cdc on mass
many businesses around town are tossing
the match requirement
out the window but that raises the
question can they ask customers
for proof of vaccination we spoke to a
legal expert to find out
most people are not wearing masks when
they come in grouchy john's coffee just
made masks
optional for customers co-owner j.j
wiley tells me that's because some
patrons were picking fights with
employees over the weekend
and they want to avoid any arguments we
can't feasibly
ask every customer what their
vaccination status is so it's kind of an
honor system that we're relying on
other businesses are taking a different
approach the honor system is a joke
girl clothing ceo courtney olsen says
once her storefront opens in june she'll
still require
masks for everyone just keep it simple
like wear a mask
the we don't want people having to prove
whether or not they've had a vaccine
but if a business wanted to ask for
proof is that legal
it's well within their rights attorney
aisha medley says non-healthcare
businesses
can ask for proof of vaccination since
they will not be violating hipaa laws
but there are rules they have to follow
if you're asking for that health
information just be sure that you do
have to follow
state identity theft laws and privacy
laws while grouchy johns is hopeful
customers will tell the truth they have
some safeguards in place
i know that they're you know there are
probably people who are going to fudge
things just because they don't want to
wear masks
which is why we're keeping the match
requirement in place for our
crew and employees
while some local businesses are still
deciding what to do
big box stores such as target walmart
and costco
are getting rid of mass requirements for
those who are fully vaccinated
reporting live from downtown las vegas
tonight orca mana 8 news now